but I don't agree overall with the uh
the standard dress code people expect
you know suit wearing and stuff and so
the important thing to consider is we
kick the segment off
Donald Trump ate a well done steak with
ketchup it was a 30-day dry aged steak
at a fancy restaurant and they said how
do you want it says well done with
ketchup and the media mocked and
insulted him for it but Trump is smart
he laid the Trap when the media came out
and started insulting Trump for for
eating a steak well done with ketchup a
lot of poor people in this country eat
their steaks well done with ketchup they
can't afford the good fancy 30-day dry
aged steaks they want something that
just tastes good and they slap some
ketchup on it and that's that's for some
people not everybody you know there are
poor people who understand the Finer
Things in life and know how to make a
good steak I'm not saying that's not
true but right now the the Democrats
trying to lay us they're trying to use
fetterman as the Everyman a guy who's
just wearing Odeon shorts it's a regular
working probably not his real outfit
that's what I was thinking right so
exactly he probably goes home off camera
and puts a suit on and